O'Brien from Sanjay Gupta CNN you ask
what's the most interesting idea you've
heard today and will keep you motivated
I think the most interesting idea I've
heard today is the idea of personalizing
all of medicine it's this idea that that
all of us are genetically different some
way the way that we're treated in the
way that prevention is what it takes
place what is through looking at our DNA
and what I thought was really
interesting is of that that sort of idea
which was hypothetical for so long is
actually happening now there are people
that are doing this sequence and the
entire genome of lots and lots of people
and determining you had a best treat
people so if you have one camp suitable
for tumor is going to be a little bit
different life than the next person is
lung cancer so what is the specific
treatment that you should get after
you've developed a disease and also most
importantly how to prevent it in our
first place if you're motivated is
issues like this I am convinced that
there is a huge intersections between
technology in medicine and sort of the
space that i have just adore and I
report on primarily and just interested
in as a service as well so they will
good luck right doctor sent by creating
people together to build these an omen
community